hi uh we make sure I'm here in the
camera my name is Paco and thank you
appreciate the opportunity to speak I
wanted to talk about an open-source
project we started this out for taking a
look at the community around Apache
spark but now I'm doing some work with
it at O'Reilly trying to look at open
source communities for a number of
different frameworks and really start to
understand some of this the structure
and the dynamics of what goes on in a
developer community by analyzing a lot
of their discussions lorena Lavernia
barbara in the keynote this morning had
excellent section about discourse
analytics and this is an attempt towards
some of that at least applying certain
techniques toward that pretty early
stages but the codes up on github and it
it is generalized enough to be able to
work with it a number of different
developer communities so part of this is
based on spark so I'll ask how many
folks have used spark before okay more
folks using spark that's great that's
like 50 ish percent one of the the main
ideas of spark is it's a great framework
for handling big data batch jobs like
you would do with Hadoop but some of the
constraints are relaxed and so not only
does it handle batch but it can also do
some interactive work and some iterative
work there was waste user for streaming
it's based off of functional programming
and leveraging closures you know in a to
describe a pipeline and that works very
well with with lambda expressions in
Python or you know also closures in
Scala and and are consequently you can
translate from sequel queries into
functional programming net does this was
something called link and Scala really
borrowed ideas definitely from that you
can also do machine learning graph
algorithms I'll show some this in a bit
so SPARC is kind of a generalized
framework for a lot of different types
of
data processing and I think one thing
that really says it strongly is Hadoop
was really based off of 2002 Google was
having troubles with spinning discs when
they had thousands of servers in a
cluster and they wanted a fault-tolerant
kind of framework to get large-scale
jobs run over the top of that and so
they came up with GFS they came up with
MapReduce how do you of course is an
open source implementation of MapReduce
but it was really based off of some of
the trade-offs in engineering back in
2002 2003 spark came along a decade
later and you know things have really
changed in open-source sorry in
commodity hardware things have really
changed
comparing 2003 with say 2010 you know a
decade later we have multi-core large
memory spaces SSDs much faster
networking and but still we have a lot
of servers fail so SPARC is a way of
providing fault tolerance but really
using about a decade later generation of
hardware and one of the things is that
spark last year the team took the the
world record in the gray sort challenge
a hundred terabytes sort and previously
been held by Yahoo using Hadoop and
spark team was able to do it with a
cluster that was one-tenth the size and
three times as fast and they scaled it
out to a petabyte and they still saw
pretty nice linear ramp about a 30x
improvement on most the metrics across
the board so yeah that's a lot of what's
going on with SPARC it is it's more
recent and leveraging functional
programming one of the things you can do
is spark as I mentioned it was graphs so
if you have a graph that you want to
define in terms of a set of nodes and
then another set of the edges that
connect them in spark the basic data
abstraction low-lying data abstraction
is called an RDD a resilient distributed
data set it's a collection you can think
of it as a fault tolerant collection
then you can apply functions to so if
you take and take a graph you can
represent it as an RDD of the nodes and
another RDD of the edges connecting them
you compose that into a graph object and
then you can apply
functions to the graph object and the
results that that comes out is an RDD so
graphs work very well this came out of
implementation of GraphLab api or parts
of graph live api along with an
implementation of if you've ever read
the prague old paper from google and so
really inheriting from GraphLab this
would graphics really leverages graph
parallel systems that would be the class
of problem that would fit well in the
case with SPARC what's very interesting
there is how well it integrates with the
rest of the workflow so for instance you
might use say spark sequel to be doing
your ETL preparing your data to put into
the graph or you might have spark
streaming where you're taking in live
feeds off of receivers and annotating
updating a graph or it might be that
after you've done some kind of graph
query you run some predictive modeling
on the results so spark is very good at
integrating these pieces because it has
this kind of common substrate oh here's
some of the papers to Joseph Gonzales
who was a postdoc at Berkeley the
original graph paper there a paragraph
paper and the prego paper from Google
etc etc so here's how you can build
graphs here's a node RDD and edger RDD
and they both have a type signature so
there's some type of data associated
with node some type of data associated
with the edges and then you compose them
into a graph object now this is of
course not Python but I had an example
here in Scala
graphics itself so far it doesn't have a
full Python binding so generally it's
scholar but it's a simple traversal run
on on a graph that I've built more
complex kinds of graphs would do
optimizations so for instance there's a
implementation of Dijkstra's algorithm
if you have say you're looking at Google
Maps and you
looking at your your starting point and
maybe three possible destinations what's
the cost of going through different
routes to get to a given destination
Dijkstra's algorithm could calculate
that kind of thing typically would be
called a single source shortest path but
it's the kind of thing that Google Maps
does all day every day FedEx UPS all
these routing problems again they use it
all day every day at scale I'm going to
scoot through some of the Scala parts of
this there's really a lot of graph work
there I'll get to a implementation part
later partly because of time here one
thing though I will say is that graphs
are very interesting for a wide range of
data here I'll be showing them for some
natural language processing in kind of a
different way than is usually done but a
lot of real-world problems fit graphs
and so if you're looking at optimizing
sales in you know funnel kind of
analysis that can be a graph if you're
looking at supply chain that can be a
graph so a wide range of data is of
course linked data and many of these
will satisfy graph parallel systems and
they can be run well in something like
graph lab or graphics another thing is
that graphs can generally be converted
into sparse matrices and a lot of times
it may be more efficient to just convert
them and then run parallel algorithms on
your matrices for instance Facebook uses
giraffe Apache giraffe and they have
trillion element graphs and then you
know very proud of showing what they can
do there Twitter came along a little bit
later after Facebook and rather than
investing into really large scale graph
stuff they instead invested into algebra
and scalding and ways of doing very
efficient parallel processing on
matrices so I'm not going to go into
that too much except that well if you
have a graph so you have four points
there you can convert it into a matrix
and then you can start to do fun when
your algebra kinds of things with
eigenvalues and eigenvectors cetera
factorization is all that lets get oh
there is one thing I will say though
I've definitely been try
just seed this notion if you have a
graph that's more complex that doesn't
just have one attribute on each edge
maybe it has multiple edges between the
same nodes maybe multiple kinds of
attributes something that's collecting a
lot of different data a very very rich
kind of graph then you wouldn't
typically be doing work with matrices at
that point I mean you can can you can
you can kind of shoehorn it into that
I've seen those attempts generally not a
good idea not a general-purpose case
kind of thing but if you're talking
about complex graphs with multiple types
of connections on them tensors are the
general case and what's interesting is
there is a lot of work or there's some
very interesting work with general cased
tensor factorization and scale some of
it on spark anima an an Kumar at Irvine
I think has some of the better
presentations about this and if so graph
algorithms will start to become very
very very interesting because it will
knock down a lot of real-world cases so
watch that case especially and I think
we're kind of on the cusp of that so
getting to the heart of this one there
is a project called X tow it's a fun
github and it's about insights into
developer communities the idea is that
we have a very rich set of data in terms
of the email forums that developers for
a particular project are using so if
you're talking about Apache spark
there's user dot user at spark till
Apache or go there's death at sparked at
Apache org and the project itself really
tries to reinforce that the committers
are active in these forms every day they
handle all kinds of newbie questions
they're really really engaged and when
people come and ask questions about
spark and other channels either to say
you know what go to the email form so
it's it's a very rich way of taking a
look at what's going on with the
developer community so we started
thinking about ways to leverage some
data mining now when you look at the
email list there are sequences there are
threads of email and there are sequences
of messages along these threads somebody
start some other people start answering
pretty soon when you follow the trail of
that you've got a graph so you can think
of this graph structure of the senders
and the receivers of an email form
that's interesting you've also got time
stamps on this data so all the messages
are sent at a particular time or
received at a certain time so you've got
graph data you've got some time series
data and of course it's text so there
could be interesting things with natural
language you know as far as parsing it
some semantic analysis maybe some
sentiment analysis things like that so
what we did we came up with a project
called exto and linking this up over
here
that's probably is that big enough to
read Begley okay it's called exto and
the thing is you can point it at pretty
much any Apache developer community the
email forums for them they tend to all
follow the same pattern there's the
archives that Apache has so you can just
point it at a different URL and and
start to crawl a different list of
course when you're doing this for spark
but it can be applied to others now the
other thing is that here's a paper that
part of this talk is based on it's from
Radamel hacia at michigan now she had
formulated using PageRank to do some
text analytics I'll show this in a
moment and actually here's here's an a
simple bit of data if you go to let's
look at Jen Jen one there we go
so TV my friend tathagata daus who leads
on spark streaming here's like I guess
the first message of the year so you
know scraping these is not too much for
a problem cleaning up the text is a
little bit more problematic there's one
other data source in this and that is
right here it's a Google Doc and we just
we keep track although I'm a few days
behind here we keep track of the
different meetups and conference talks
about spark around the world and so
we've been doing that since last October
we have a nice little backlog there
which is interesting because
now we can do some analytics about you
know what speakers are speaking most
frequently what companies are most
engaged what are the topics what are the
cities things like that and I think it's
very interesting when you start to put
together some learnings about the
developer community because of the email
forums but then be able to join this
with some other learnings from say the
meetups
okay so first I'm going to focus on
looking at the email list archives and
being able to well show the pipeline for
be able to crawl this and parse it and a
couple things are important here this is
one of the most active projects at
Apache it comes out to being about 2000
messages per month that's not a lot of
data points per se and each email
message is not that large really works
out to being an average of about 18
megabytes per month this is when the you
know email list has been crawled and
each email message is represented as a
JSON document so 18 megabytes per month
that's really that's kind of trivial I
mean I can definitely fit that on to you
know USB stick if we take a look at
what's actually in there six months of
activity will start to build a graph
that's a bit more complex than that
though there is about 2,000 senders and
if we start to build up a representation
of the topic modeling we can get into
graphs that have millions of elements
and them very quickly and what this says
is you could have relatively small
source data but a very large compute
problem okay if I want to do some
complex analytics on that graph some
complex algorithms it can really chew up
a lot of compute time even though it's
relatively small data so that's
interesting it does satisfy graph
parallel systems so there's lots of data
locality to leverage you can do this in
parallel whether you're doing it
parallel on your multi-core laptop or a
parallel on a cluster that's still the
same kind of thing now I've shown before
kind of an
idealized machine learning workflow and
I this is just kind of a template to
think about applications when I'm
building them but you know typically
there's multiple data sources there's a
lot of work to clean up the data some
type of ETL and then from there you'll
probably go in and spend a lot of time
exploring and exploring data new data is
a hard problem it's not something that's
readily automated it really does require
some understanding and some learning
about the problem you may be able to use
some machine learning techniques to
augment how you explore you might be
using some unsupervised learning
clustering etc but typically you know
you're not gonna be doing a lot of
modeling instead this layer right here
this stage is more about reporting and
visualization from there you can move on
to features from there move on to
building some models and then they're
evaluating the models future engineering
is a hard problem deep learning is one
way to approach some Auto encoding and
alleviating some of the difficulties of
feature engineering but is still gonna
be a hard problem and the reason for
that is that people really only think
well and about three or four dimensions
not beyond that
whereas in complex datasets you can
start to get thousands of dimensions
very quickly so features future
engineering can be a very
counterintuitive kind of thing
evaluation is another part that's very
difficult to automate very very hard to
do because if you don't evaluate your
machine learning models the right way
you can really shoot yourself in the
foot that can be very sneaky so I wanted
to show in red where the hard parts are
in a typical kind of pipeline like this
for what I'm showing in this part here
we'll take it up to exploration and take
a look at some queries and then we'll do
a little bit of future engineering to
prepare for building a model haven't
quite got to the model in yet so here
for preparing the data and then we'll do
some some exploring first off this is
going to be based on we're taking JSON
documents for each message and then
using NLT kay
to be able to do actually there's a
wrapper on top of n LT K that's called
text blob I really like that a lot
better especially some of the part of
speech tagging I think is it's better
performance than what you see in alt K
but I've got in Python a scraper for the
email lists and then a parser to do a
little bit of light parsing I'll show
examples that also of signing unique IDs
and basically preparing the data so they
can be fit into graphs so here we're
gonna come from Apache email lists and
then we're going to crawl that one of
the harder problems with email is that
you get a lot of quoted text and maybe
several levels of quoted text so an
issue there is being able to filter out
the quoted text and you typically end up
with fairly light not a lot of data not
a lot of text and that makes the text
analytics more difficult that's why this
technique is used
there's also segmentation and then
tagging that we do on the on the
messages so when we crawl it comes out
to a JSON doctor looks like this and
then when we parse it we'll take that
jason and we'll go through the text cut
it into sentences and then for each
sentence we'll split it into words and
then for each word tag it determine is
it a noun is an adjective is it a verb
if it's a noun or a verb for instance if
it's a plural noun let's find the
singular form if it's a verb let's find
the root so we'll find the most
canonical form for that word and that's
using some sort of some sources out of n
ltk tree bank and wart net word net to
do the limit ization
we also in text blob there's some
sentiment analysis so we can take a look
at the sentences and start to score them
look at the paragraphs as well and try
to give them some scores you know which
direction is just leaning and another
thing is since we do have these lists of
the sentences and we have the words all
segmented out we'll go through and we'll
apply a technique called skip gram
where we're taking a look at say there's
a noun followed by an adjective and then
further down the sentence there's a verb
we'll take and create a skip crammed
with a window of 3 and start to link
some of the words together again into a
graph if they are collocated but also if
they happen to have the same root we'll
also link across the sentences so by
virtue of doing this we'll take a piece
of text a paragraph and convert it into
a graph and the graph is structured
based on how the words are next to each
other and how the words share meaning
and so the idea of text rank is if you
take that graph and run PageRank on it
then the words that have essentially
more sinks into them have more meaning
applied more reference it's just like
webpages that have more inbound links
and so by running PageRank then you can
figure out which phrases are being most
commonly referenced and therefore
they're probably the ones that are a
better approximation of the text overall
so it looks like this if I take the the
data coming in I've got that doc I run
it through my pipeline and then coming
out I've got a paragraph that's
segmented I've got some kind of ID I've
got a couple of different metrics to
describe the sentiment subjectivity and
polarization and and also I do some
tiling basically the Skip Graham to link
the different words together that are
related now if you want to grab some of
the data for this I've got it all up
several months of the Apache spark list
I have on a public s3 bucket so if you
want try running this the data is
already scraped in parsed okay so let me
show some code right here and this is
going to be in a notebook I have this in
a few formats I was doing this off of
data bricks so it'll be Python in sorry
I don't want this one I want this one
it'll be Python in a notebook and I
could run this in Jupiter or I could run
this in
in in this case in database cloud I just
had it in data bricks cloud but I also
exported it so it could be run in
Jupiter and that's in the open source
project the idea is that I take and
create an RDD that points to my
collection of JSON documents and I
registered the RDD as a temp table and
so now it's in the catalog and I can run
sequel queries against it if I take a
look for six months of data there's yeah
thirteen thousand messages that make
sense if I take a look at what a raw
message looks like you see the the Jason
there spark is smart enough that when it
reads in Jason it can take a union
across all the different documents in an
RDD and then synthesize what is the
schema so once you read in the JSON you
can say print schema and it'll show you
what it thinks is the overall queryable
schema so now that we've got this we can
start to do some queries if I'm going to
explore a community first off I want to
know who are the people involved so a
very simple query to find out who are
the senders and then I actually create a
map so that each sender has a unique ID
it's a very simple pipeline here and in
spark you can see I've got this data
structure down here basically a
dictionary that describes the the
different senders involved the different
people and their email is involved and a
unique ID for each okay so now that I
know who and I have IDs let's start to
refine this what's interesting is let's
see who are the most frequent senders
that's better information
I'd like to characterize them in more
subtle ways but the topcase senders is
important so here I'm actually doing in
Python in spark that's a word count
pretty much it would be very similar as
if I were going to write as a word count
and then I've actually sorted it by key
so if I print that out here again based
on the functional programming approach I
can show who the topcase senders are
just printing that out as a list of key
values or
I could also Express this as a sequel
query and then this will be translated
down and run the same way as if I do the
the Python pipeline so here in our
community you can see that Sean Owen
from cloud era is means out there a lot
and uh akhil boss from sigmoid is out
there a lot Michael arborist is actually
the lead author run spark sequel so he's
there of course but you know it's
interesting I mean these are really the
people who are very much engaged
many of them are committers and if
they're not committers their consultants
are they're very much in the community
okay so top cake that's one way to look
at the shape of the community it's a
very simple way to build a leaderboard
maybe not the best well let's take a
look and see account of messages
compares with duration of time what I
think so it's really curious about is if
there's like a drive by email so if
somebody comes in they sort of get in
the community they fire up a lot of
messages and then they go away and they
never come back and so I wanted to try
to come up with a metric for that and
what I'm doing here is I've set up a
function the timestamps are all strings
so we're going to convert them and
create a float out of that and then from
there we're gonna take a look at date
ranges in a numeric way and find out if
a particular person who is seems to be
engaged in the community if they're
actually there consistently are they
over a long period of time so we're
basically taking a look at the the count
the frequency of them engaging along
with the duration of them engaging look
at two dimensions and for those you who
are into that sort of thing Pareto
fronts might be a good way to describe
that okay so here's a query to show
count and duration now after I have
transform the data here in this pipeline
I busy creating a different data frame
and then I query against it and it turns
out Sean Owen is there almost every day
and I should talk to his boss about that
no I'm just kidding Sean's a great guy
and he's very very much part of this far
community so the rankings here didn't
change a whole lot the people who were
there
pretty much there all the time some of
them did shift and that's interesting
and I could add more dimensions to try
to quantify who what does this community
look like but this is good because it
really these names are very familiar
these are people who are and you know
they're they're the speakers that spark
summit a lot Muslim okay I want to carry
to understand a little bit more about
the community so here we're going to
take a look and say well we want to look
at the subject of the message and we
want to look at the sender and then we
want to look at the person who replies
so it did the reply message look at the
sender for that and call them or well
we've got sender and receiver and okay
so basically we can come out and say
well here's a list of different people
who are responding to each other about
particular topics so that's interesting
who talks with whom and particularly for
the the high frequency topics this is
very interesting because it means that
pairs of people are engaged on the same
topic repeatedly or over a period of
time and that's an important thing to
understand about your community
sometimes people answer themselves and
so here's a person actually let me do
there so here's somebody who answered
his own message
36 times so that's interesting
apparently knew a lot about this topic
and I I should actually send email to
this person and find out what was going
on there but we do see some of these
kind of artifacts and you know maybe
that's good to filter out it's not it
doesn't really fit the kind of model
we're trying to do with graphs okay so
let's see here send a reply err I wanted
to get some counts on who are the
couplets of people the basically the
pairs in the graph who's said to be seem
to be talking to each other very
frequently and that's interesting
because I might want to see what company
they come from or what organization
they're in maybe that's consistent or
maybe maybe there's a consulting firm
that's helping out a client over the
list that definitely happens a lot too
good so those are flavors of different
queries that we can do to try to
understand just even looking from
timestamps and subjects and and the you
know the from-from headers we can start
to figure out some of the dynamics of
the list I'd like to go a lot deeper
okay so what I'm gonna do is build up a
large-scale graph and I'm gonna do this
using Parque
so I'll take the edges and I'm going to
overlay some types on them and then
write out a park a file to represent all
of the edges and then I'll do the same
thing with the nodes all overlay types
on those and write it out as Parque
ephod how many folks have used Parque
some okay let's say five ten percent the
idea of Parque is this if you have a
record and you have a lot of fields in a
record so you have a hundred fields in a
record when you go to store your data
you could take it row by row and if
you're gonna compress the data well
that's interesting each row will be
compressed let's say that or maybe just
the whole files compressed another way
to organize this would be to say org and
I basically split it on the columns and
compress the columns together that makes
more sense because logically within a
column you'll probably see repeats of
data values so there's probably more
opportunities to get better compression
there so that's great so Parque will
look at things in a column wise way and
do some really great compression on the
data now that actually fits well with
key value stores with some of the
columnar storage frameworks like
Cassandra or Vertica accumulo etc so now
we've got a nice way to serialize the
data that fits well with these
distributed frameworks but there's more
to it than that Parque can also take
predicates pushdown predicates so if I
have expressed in Pais Park a pipeline
and it has a filter and I'm doing some
kind of select I could essentially take
those predicates and instead of doing
them in SPARC I could push them all the
way down into Parque
and that's where you get really great
optimizations because parquet is smart
enough to say number one I've got a
hundred columns in my record I'm only
going to query three of them so first
off let's only you know decompress
deserialize those three columns forget
everything else so you get huge
efficiencies there number two if you've
got these predicates that would be up in
the pipeline but you can push them down
like a filter scan great we'll do that
while we're decompressing the data and
boom we have all kinds of savings and
then another point is something called
code gen it's possible to say look at
the closures of what's being described
and PI spark and compile those and send
that down into part K so it's actually
not interpreting the running compiled
code and code gen will get by you a lot
lot more so park' is really nice
practice there's also OCR and there's
there's some others that i've heard of
in the works but these are really great
ways to handle your storage because
spark itself doesn't do really anything
for storage so now I've got some data to
be able to do some graph analysis and I
better get going here on this talk how
late I have okay good here I've got a
graph okay what I'm gonna do is not just
keep a graph of the people who are
talking to each other I'm gonna keep a
graph of all the text semantically so
recall that earlier on each message was
split into sentences and the sentences
were parsed and then they were tagged
and then with the Skip Graham's we
constructed a graph out of each each
text document so we're gonna take that
each word is going to be a node and then
the the links between them are the edges
and we'll do a similar thing where we
write these out as park' so we've got
graph edge and graph node as park' okay
now at this time I'm going to do
something that's complete heresy but
I'll show a little bit of Scala because
so far they have not got this in Python
yet but we've prepared all the data in
Python so I think is that fair anybody
give me permission okay
so this is kind of fun this is a type of
text analytics NLP that used to be
really expensive and so it wasn't done
very much but now it's getting cheaper
and so what we'll do is first off read
in the park' files now with spark you
have this thing called lazy evaluation
so when I say read it in all I'm doing
is defining a graph to be executed later
I'm not actually reading in all that
data and so that's nice because it's
part K so maybe I can prune some columns
or push some predicates I'm just for
this one here I'm just gonna tie it to
one message so that it's easier to
actually see the results but it could be
writing the whole graph at the time and
now I'll import some graphics libraries
and read in the the nodes and then
convert them to RTD and then read in the
edges and convert them to RDD and this
is the nodes and edges for the parsed
text
I'll take those two rdd's and compose
them into a graph right here so I get a
graph G and then I read PageRank and in
graphics you know this is a one-line
call PageRank is implemented in prego
it's about five lines in prickled but
it's already there and optimized so I
say PageRank and I give it a conversion
threshold right there and once that's
calculated I'll just grab the vertices
out the results basically the ranks for
each word that'll be a vector and when I
ran this on a small cluster it took like
16 seconds no big deal that was actually
pretty good and now I've got a vector of
the different ranks in the different
words I'll overlay a little schema on
them and register it create a data frame
register as a temp table and then I can
query against it so looking at this one
particular message if I look at the
ranks that came out of PageRank memory
has a certain rank persist etc etc I've
got the highly ranked words that's like
keyword analysis it's not really all
that great so what I'd like to do is
instead basically pull a thread so for
every highly ranked word I'm gonna take
a look at it surrounding noun phrase and
just pull the thread on those and
aggregate the ranks together and I'll
come up with this other metric that
describes basically which of the most
highly ranked phrases this is a way of
doing automated document summarization
so if you've ever read a scientific
paper and they've got the column where
somebody's abstracted it and they've got
some key phrases to describe the paper
that's what way of doing it
automatically so here I will take and
read back in the fully parsed data and
register that and do a little bit of
join well actually we'll just take a
look at this particular message and see
what's in there there's the parse data
and then here you scoot down a little
bit what I'm gonna do is a little bit of
scala to take and extract off basically
pull the thread on the noun phrases
extract up those and aggregate their
other page ranks together and once I do
that I've got phrases let's query that
it comes out and says okay memory crunch
is the top-ranked MapReduce operations
is next iterative algorithms is next
memory persist etc and that's great
because when you look at the raw text
it's right here I know is that readable
is that big enough maybe a little bigger
when you look at the raw text you know
they said only fit the data in memory
where you want to run the iterative
algorithm for MapReduce operations it's
better not to cache if you have a memory
crunch so it actually did pick up the
right now and phrases now there's a a
really cheap and dirty way of doing that
now I'm phrase chunking but it gets ya
the results are muscle - it's it's it's
it's a little dicey
so I wanted to have something that would
hit and get the right noun phrases in a
much more reliable way text drunk will
do that it is a graph algorithm it's
relatively expensive but if you can do
text rank in parallel it's it's working
out pretty well now if you were just to
do this in terms of keyword analysis you
would see the you memory - and
basically a really flat view of this
message it's not as rich
okay so let's scoot back over I'm gonna
skip the docker section in the interest
of time basically this algorithm text
rank was done by retina hacia and
paltrow at UNT it'll read is at Michigan
now and there are implementations in
English Spanish and Icelandic also if
you need Icelandic and you know here's
like a really heavy dense math paragraph
out of a paper and talking about linear
Diophantine equations but you see it
creates a graph and then it doesn't
really care what's in there
light parsing a little bit of semantic
markup and then lamb you just do
PageRank on it okay social graph is the
last thing I'll do
I also took and ran the the connection
of people talking to each other and so
we did PageRank on that it's better than
looking and seeing who are the top K
you're actually looking at who is
referencing whom so you build up a much
richer view of who are the important
influencers in this community now we can
take a look at maximum degree max op
degree etc etc connecting components etc
basically it comes out like this you do
have a different ranking the top three
are still preserved but then other
people move up and down and it does
actually I think represent better in
terms of the dynamics of this community
I used to be the Evangelist for Apache
spark so you know that's kind of my
experiences who's who in the community
but Shawn Owen is definitely at the top
and another thing that popped out of
this I don't think we show it there are
connected components basically are their
cliques in the graph as it turned out no
this graph it does not have a lot of
little cliques and it's because the the
committers are actually really active
engaging with all the new people who
come in all the intro questions so you
get a lot of connectivity across the
graph so that was a pretty interesting
learning but now we can take and point
it to a bunch of other types of forms as
well not just not just spark and so what
we're doing is to put this in
to a notebook and publish it through
Jupiter and come up with leaderboards to
describe a variety of popular
open-source projects and you know who
who's who in the community and who
should go talk with we think that
that'll be interesting the surface
there's a lot of other ways to try to
quantify or understand these communities
but it's a pretty interesting kind of
metric already I think I'm probably over
time I know we started late but are
there any questions I could take just
for brief yes yet most certainly yes I I
have on slideshare.net I am puck wide
I'm a Paco humanoid so paka wide and
I've actually got a few different
versions of this one other questions yes
yes yes yes so that was one of the
points of using text blob so it's a text
blob is a Python layer on top of the ltk
on top of word net and they have a
really nice statistical well they have a
nice parser a nice segmentation but what
I found was the part of speech tagger
there was much better than any other I
could find and I ran tests across a
variety of difference so I like the
Python library the best and one of the
things I do is in the original paper
radda used porter stemmer and you know
got reasonable results I went back in
and did limit ization which is say I do
lookups after the parse the sentence I
look up the the word in word net and if
it's a verb I find its root and so you
actually get a much cleaner
representation this way and better
convergence you can take it a step
further if you want to do something akin
to a random walk you can go into word
net and look at if you're familiar with
like hyper names and hypo names you can
take and start to build out the graph
based on looking at the word sense
vectors and build out other edges and
you get a denser graph and it converges
better
yeah I mean yeah they're out there I
mean you could do a lot of those are
like chunking kind of things and I've
compared them I used this for custom
search engine for Rolling Stone part of
how they surface their back catalog and
you know get advertising and revenue off
of that and and we did some bake ups on
this and and this will definitely give
you for most of the articles we were
getting better performance here we were
also doing co-occurrence we were doing a
variety you kind of built this ensemble
of different approaches but you know at
the end of the day we took the results
and drop him into leucine so we can do
fast look ups and so we would compare it
against other algorithms that way good
question any other questions probably
the other talk is coming in here soon so
I can take some questions off the slide
thank you very much appreciate